this is historical friction by the way
his seats just lower look like I'm like
this is not our real IDs but I anyone
this season normally knows it's not a
real eye today um but uh funny how you
picked the higher seat well because I'm
high as a kite right now you have to be
in order to talk few logs about Steven
universe I mean come on what sober
person would do that
so has it just been this one guy's
family has been mayor for 200 years I
guess
as does the SHA he was the first with a
great great great great grandpa whatever
was the first one we've got this guy now
I feel like that's being implied somehow
it's are we really shocked I mean if I
mean there's still bushes and Clinton's
I think Obama of the equation it's like
Bush Clinton Bush Clinton and you with
Obama in there we're probably gonna get
another possibly again our Clinton I
mean it's like if I would did you say
it's like it's precious a royal family
now it's nothing but I could not a
republic know we're a monarchy
we've got elected monarchs like a
fucking Phantom Menace yeah that's
pretty much it elects the new queen of
Naboo so yeah bottom line anyone
watching that's not America we know our
politics is a joke that's why I'm voting
for Cooper
so pretty much Trump yeah they even kind
of look alike about the hair the same
the attitude the the horns and spikes on
his head are the same absolutely and the
scales show about really anyone across
thumb what I did I think I did want to
make sure is beer boy they're gonna
wonder is this like an Obama shirt or
like uh no it'sit's Koopa bong Koopa
it's coupe AMA yeah all the people
they're like cuz we always hear who
aren't put together with it
clump weights a clump of something oh so
just anyone that brought American is
watching just we know we know our
politics as a joke right no it's kind of
it for a while but it's Oh trust me we
yeah we some of us are I in Canada I
find it worth it but yeah and we're just
fingers crossed it it doesn't go the
route that everyone thinks it's gonna go
but well that's it let's talk about this
I guess propaganda play this turn out is
propaganda and then turned into
something really entertaining um you
know a lot of things to say about this
first of all I love how you know that
problem that happened what three four
episodes ago is still taking place I
mean that big friction no the problem is
watching these in these little clumps
over the course of a week and then we
had a break for a little bit like I
still I have the OPP's approach of like
that's still going on like I actually
it's okay I just a part of he's just
like yeah you could wrap that up and I'd
be okay now like you know I like how do
I put if there wasn't too much time to
adjust Stephen coming in and her just
sir sitting up like that just oh hey
Stephen stuff like that's all you need
it's fine it's fine I don't really have
a problem I just it surprises me I'm
just like oh I guess that's still going
on like I guess I'm too used to cartoons
where that just wouldn't even be
referenced than what you even in this
show that is usually like for the most
part like I have power ramp ups and
stuff but I really dive in the 10 15
there wrap ups um but I like that still
thing but it's not dwelled on too much
it's just little hints here and there
it's still the episodes about something
else
um baikin tying to that as well I like
she feels like she's being useful and
helping out on everything
uh this mailman guy who I think we've
only seen once or twice uh you know I
was asking myself why do I like this guy
not ronaldo cuz they're kind of similar
and there's something about not a
fucking raging douchebag yeah there's
something about like he's clearly
delusional but I am sorry and it doesn't
get a book for ya that there's more of
an innocence to his and there's more of
a passion there's more of a love where
with Ronaldo it feels like he just kind
of wants attention and in all the wrong
ways where
sky you feel like he wants attention to
but it's kind of like for more innocent
sweet ways and sweet reasons uh
Ronaldo's like that person on the
internet you never want to run into yeah
and there's something about right with
the kool-aid and also believes it
I mean he's even sort of doing these
over-the-top gestures and stuff but
they're not too over-the-top they're
like both really over-the-top and kind
of subtle because he'll he'll do these
things like this but it's not really
like he doesn't oh boy bravado like this
he'll still be very quiet
and it's it's a great um two opposites
going a each other just say it's really
over-the-top and something it's really
quiet uh go on a chair that just feels
like this very entertaining funny little
character he's not a d-bag yeah is just
not um not a douche bag you know when I
saw them put on the play I was kind of
thinking myself you know I I'm wondering
if I really want to see this cuz it's
gonna be the two of them and I don't I
haven't seen a ton of this guy but I
side didn't like or dislike I was like
but now he's gonna be all the roles this
is gonna work and I thought that's
really charming like I was watching home
movies yeah it really felt like home it
was funny um there's this genuineness to
him where I think with Ronaldo to like
even when he's doing his stuff his
filming stuff he knows he's being phony
where I think this guy really feels he's
being genuine and dramatic I think
that's a big part of it too like when he
throws the larboard role whatever he
throws himself on those cardboard
cutouts like you really feel like no I'm
really gonna convince the audience out
there and I'm really ended it I believe
it so this is our this is Patrick what
Renauld would be like I want them to
believe with them to get angry I want
like he just wants to spread misery um
and yeah it is it is everything bad
about the internet rolled into one yeah
um you need to believe me listen to me
attention attention
some know the yoga I loved at first I
was tempted to believe that pearl
embellished things from her point of
view but by the time the play was that I
was like now I believe it yeah no
husband I believe this is legit I like
pearl embellishing hey yeah well even
like you know if she was gonna tell her
something like she would give herself an
even bigger role it would just be her
doing everything but they show that it's
oh my god and the way he dressed up is
those characters yeah the box forgot my
head and it's just a mop love Francis
yeah which I get knowing purl riding it
you can see she was just give her like
the smallest party um but what is kinda
neat seeing how this you know this town
is discovered um but even then they
can't say like this is dangerous land
don't cross here and stuff and I did we
say they say it was Pennsylvania's
everything so it was or well no it did
okay so like people just say it's that
Pennsylvania it's it's something I know
it's not fucking Pennsylvania but it was
a spoof of Pennsylvania where they were
going in that one episode where they're
at is I'm assuming Jersey Delaware
somewhere in there
well what I'm wondering I hug I don't
know I don't know what fake state name
they're using but Beach City I'm
thinking Jersey don't like one of those
beach towns and has like a boardwalk and
a little amusement park but you see them
all over the kind of upper mid atlantic
lower Northeast well again it's trying
to figure out kind of when this is
taking place cuz I guess I'm assuming
it's the future because we think they're
traveling to different worlds but
they're not it's all on earth and earth
obviously looks very dangerous figure
it's some sort of alternative kind of
earth in present time that might be I
know yeah um animes do that all the time
it's just like earth only it's not it's
like but it but it's like earth except
steampunk took over you know yeah then
so yeah I mean that sounding like Lee um
you know that's my guess and nobody
questions what that giant mountain
sculpture is or anything like that I
mean they just kind of know um but there
does still seem to be like this weird
reaction to the gems like some people
know about and some people don't
um you know or what they are how they
work and everything so it's if they're
make totally clear but that doesn't mean
it's like a flub or anything I mean it
could very well be just know it is
explained in their world they just
haven't explained to us yet um and I get
the feeling they would have that figured
out so but
again the Chi as to the mystery and I
like that it's like the gems are trying
to stop them say no like this area
really is dangerous you don't know so
we're crap that goes on here at the guy
want to go on anyway I just figured
that's because the gems are there so
like no you won't be where we are this
is this well they know that trouble
always kind of follows them too but
again like what is that mountain
sculpture and stuff I mean clear stuff
must have happens around that is there
hope
well no no by me like did did they did
they sculptor was it always there was
there civilization there uh you know the
wars and stuff that it was more money
intrigue on Dorian's to ward off
invaders and say hey this belongs to the
men or gems house guys I don't think
they are med mentions um but I just want
to see Frodo Sam and Aragorn like both
by that thing like staring up in it big
epic music um I do all that no we got
rowed out but we never do talk about
that thing and it's like the icon of the
show it's in every episodes in every
title card and the opening and stuff and
I do freaking love that thing I never do
talk about it um I always thought it for
a long time I thought that was rose I
thought could they always talk about
roses memory and stuff and then when we
see written Oh it's where they worship
Kali and rip out all the hearts of the
people they don't like before this end
the demo loved it so there is a lava pit
under oh yeah okay very noses
yeah and then eventually Stephens gonna
be like you'll be treasurer that would
be amazing Shay I'm not saying you have
to do that Rebecca sugar but if you
could just animate like a three-minute
clip of that that would be a maze for
Kali just in hell yeah just know that it
as an easter egg
I love the disks I just I just need to
see that once before I die well you have
a connection to her so higher if I read
death row that would be my love my final
wish is like if you could make that
happen and my final meal uh sushi we do
not have a connection with her by the
way because we do have a connect you
with some people we don't have a
connection with her oh no because if we
did that would have happened or I didn't
have happy harassing her and that's
talking out of write that say and she'd
be like cool um so yeah I thought this
was a very charming episode indeed
remind me a little bit of the the play
episode from Avatar a little bit sorry
on cardboard cutouts it reminded me of
the play episode from home movies when
it's the mom still painting the set oh
yeah yeah watch out you have the enemy
at home movies it's amazing shows um but
uh yeah I thought was very I thought was
very likeable I liked all the characters
in it um a quick question what do you
think of mayor Dewey as a character we
we all both love Joel like he's always
great but wait you think of him as a
character well sirs I think it could use
a little work what do you think sirs i
OneNote yeah
like it's just a OneNote spoofy kid yeah
you know it's like Spaceballs and
presidents group it's is like Oh or or
the governor and Blazing Saddles I'm
like oh he's an idiot politician ha ha
hmm
I don't other than that I don't like I
don't sit here and go oh my god a mayor
Dewey episode I mean it's nice to hear
Johansson oh yeah it's like it's it's
nice because he's doing the voice but
the character itself I'm like yeah no I
don't hate him but at the same time I'm
not sitting here going oh my god I can't
wait yeah it's something it's always
kind of a mix of feeling cuz you know
it's like oh it's it's Joel again cuz I
love Joel but yeah whenever it's kind of
that character it's like okay like I
said it's you know exactly you're gonna
give this one note and I want to laugh
harder at him uh but that's you like you
said just kind of a generic dumb
politician that we've seen a million
times and it's you
annoy me or anything but it is like oh
it's an episode around this guy okay I'm
probably not gonna laugh that much and
even here the last didn't really come
from him it came from the characters
interpretation of what happened um you
know the only thing I was really funny
in the script was him suddenly growing
500 feet tall which I found very
humorous um butter better choice and
Trump decided shoots him over job every
day
so Trump I believe also claimed he could
grow 500 feet oh no that's just my hair
oh yeah I've done it
I have great relations with China to a
Giants and dinosaurs
oh no no Koopa has great relations with
his crew so yeah monkey
um but yeah that's a good episode I
definitely liked it I thought was a very
charming likable episode um not to melt
gels to go from there anything else you
got nope
what do you think sirs always end on a
joke sure something funny something
funny
you fucking rude